under the vaccine act you cannot sue a
vaccine company for injuring you no
matter how negligent they were no matter
how reckless they were
no matter how grievous your injury you
cannot sue them
the only exception to that is if they
knew of an injury that it's caused by
their vaccine and they failed to list it
on their manufacturer's insert all
vaccines that are recommended officially
recommended for children get liability
protection even if an adult gets that
vaccine
that's why they're going after kids but
the double blind controlled trial is
what's used for the initial approval of
virtually all vaccines to my knowledge
and we live in 2021
in most of the of the western world in a
place where we don't have to think about
deaths from measles or deaths from
diarrhea or pediatric pneumonia deaths
so you kind of have that luxury so it's
all out of sight out of mind
welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
i'm michaela peterson quick note if
you're interested in an in-person event
i have one january 20th in nashville
it's a q a come ask about the podcast
starting your own business psychedelics
health diet
whatever you want
i'm super excited to see you guys there
a bit nervous should be really fun it's
linked below or there are tickets at
zany's zany's comedy club in nashville
just type in michaela zaney's
it'll pop up
in this episode of opposing views where
i host two experts to give their
opposing views on issues
we talk about vaccines
this is a big one in this episode i had
robert f kennedy jr and amish adolja on
to discuss the safety of vaccines more
specifically covet 19 vaccines since
you're probably wondering yes robert f
kennedy jr is the son of the late
senator robert f kennedy and nephew of
the late president john f kennedy he's
now the chairman of children's health
defense and author his latest book is
titled the real anthony fauci so you
know
it's going to be interesting
he's already a new york times
bestselling author for works like crimes
against nature
overall his reputation as a defender of
the environment and children's health
precedes him amish adulterer on the
other hand is a senior scholar at the
john hopkins center for health security
whose work is focused on emerging
infectious disease pandemic preparedness
and biosecurity dr adolja has served on
u.s government panels to develop
guidelines for the treatment of
infectious disease emergencies as well
as an external advisor to the new york
city health and hospital emergency
management training program for highly
infectious diseases like anthrax
the three of us covered a range of
topics including childhood vaccination
recommended vaccine schedules in the u.s
safety of vaccines vaccine additives
injuries from vaccines the different
types of vaccines and more it was really
interesting to have both sides on maybe
the most hotly debated topic on the
planet right now you don't want to miss
this and remember hit subscribe if you
enjoy this kind of content
before we jump into this podcast
this episode is sponsored by better help
if you're looking for someone to talk to
or a therapist better help might be what
you want you've probably heard of them
better help assesses your needs and
matches you with a professional
therapist in under 48 hours it's not a
crisis line it's not self-help it's
professional therapy done securely and
online there's a broad range of
expertise available which may not be
locally available in many areas
especially nowadays the service is
available for clients worldwide you can
log into your account anytime and send a
message to your therapist you'll get
timely and thoughtful responses plus you
can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions so you won't ever have to
awkwardly sit in the waiting room as you
normally would better help is committed
to making great therapeutic matches
possible so they make it easy to change
therapists if you ever want to
sometimes there's some sketchy
therapists out there but not with better
help not to mention it's way more
affordable than traditional offline
therapy and financial aid is available
better help wants you to start living a
happier life today visit their website
and read their testimonials they're
posted daily and can be extremely
helpful in choosing a therapist they
have a special offer for our listeners
get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com peterson and join over 2
million people who've taken charge of
their mental health with the help of
experienced professionals
that's better help as in h e l p
dot com slash peterson
that's better help as an help.com
peterson or just use promo code peterson
for ten percent off enjoy the episode
robert kennedy welcome to my podcast
pleasure to meet you michaela
before we get started can you give a
brief background about who you are if
anyone doesn't know who you are and what
you do
i'm robert f kennedy engineer and i'm
the
president of
children's health
or the chairman of children's health
defense
and i i
am the recent author of a book that
comes out
next week called the real tony found
your real anthony fauci
okay
that's gonna be
that's gonna stir up some trouble
probably
um
okay i'm gonna run through a list of
questions
i'll just get right into it
what are your views on the
safety of vaccines just in general
well
you know you have to answer that
question one at a time because
um
each vaccine has different
characteristics and each and for each
one they you know you have to measure
the
the advisability of the vaccine based on
the efficacy and safety profile of that
product and and then the risk of the
infectious disease that it's trying to
prevent the problem with
on most of the vaccines currently all of
vaccines currently
um mandated the 72 doses of 16 vaccines
currently mandated for children under
the cdc schedule
is that none of them have been properly
safety tested vaccines are exempt
from pre-clinical trials that do
double-blind placebo testing the kind of
testing that we apply to every other
medical product
of vaccines don't
are not required to do that testing so
we don't know the risks of
any of the vaccines currently
mandated for our children
i actually sued
the hhs in 2018 as to for because for
many years i i've been saying that
vaccines aren't safety testing and
they've been saying yes they are
and
um so i suit them in 2018 after you're
saying you show me a single safety
testing pre-clinical
pre-license for safety testing for any
vaccine that is currently mandated for
children and after a year and a half of
litigation
hhs admitted that yes it had never
safety tested any of the vaccines
and because they're not safety tested we
don't know the risk profile
oh nobody can say with any kind of
scientific certainty whether any of
those products are averting more
injuries and deaths and they're causing
and there's a lot of indication that
many of those products
are actually
causing more death and injuries than
they are preventing
are some of the facts so you mentioned
there's a difference in safety and
efficacy between vaccines
given to children um are there ones that
are that you've seen that are definitely
more risky than others
i'd say any of the vaccines that have
aluminum in them
are vaccines that are
that have negative risk profiles
so i think probably the most dangerous
of the current vaccines of the hepatitis
b vaccine
on both
mercs products and glaxos
and the guard itself prior to the covet
vaccines the gardasil vaccines had
the worst risk profile and if you look
at you know one of the metrics we can
use is the vaccine adverse event
reporting system
which is the surveillance the post
licensure surveillance system post
marketing surveillance system
or vaccine injuries unfortunately the ad
system is also not reliable hhs's own
study
in 2010 it's called the lazarus study
found that that
system captures fewer than one percent
of vaccine injuries
oh you know really hhs has no idea how
many people are being killed or injured
by these vaccines
but we can tell that the gardasil
vaccine compared to other vaccine
many many many other people are
reporting injuries uh very very bad
injuries and deaths and they're
you know and they're also winning those
cases in some cases in the vaccine
courts
um so i would say those are probably the
two two of the worst vaccines
okay what about oh i know there was a
lot of
media coverage about the mmr vaccine and
potential dangers potential dangers
associated with it but you think that's
less of an issue than the hep b and
gardasil vaccines
yeah i think i mean mmr does not have
any metals in it
um there's a lot of injuries reported in
association with the mmr but the mmr is
also given to kids who are a little bit
older you know it's recommended before
36 months which is three years of age so
a lot of people a lot of kids are
getting it between 18 and 36.
and they're a little less vulnerable to
vaccine injury at that point but there's
a lot of injuries that are associated
with it
is there a better time to vaccinate kids
rather than right away like if you wait
until kids are three or five does it
lower the risk of vaccine injury
you know there's a lot of countries that
i mean we have the most aggressive
vaccine schedule of any country
and the countries that have um
wait a little longer
um
some of the scandinavian countries in
japan etc
have much appear to have much lower
levels of chronic diseases in the united
states there's other you know we're we
are having today a chronic disease
epidemic in our country
um we have we've gone from
in
1940 we had six percent of
our children had chronic disease by
1986 12.8 percent or 11.8 percent of
kids had chronic disease and by 2006 54
so chronic disease by by that i mean
neurodevelopmental disorders atd adhd
speech delay ticks narcolepsy
tourette syndrome
asd autism now all of these are injuries
that
if you are my age you never heard of
them when you were a kid so we never saw
these i never knew anybody with any of
those diseases
with the exception of maybe adhd
but all of these diseases
when when congress told the epa
what year did the autism epidemic start
autism has gone from one in ten thousand
in my generation and to this day it's
one in ten thousand of my i've never met
a man my age 67 years old with
full-blown autism
you know non-verbal non-toilet trained
uh stimming head-banging a toe walking
yeah you just don't see them
and they're not locked up anywhere
because there are no places for people
like that
and my kids generation so it's 1 in 10
000 according to cdc data
it's 1 in 22 in my children's generation
and when congress said to epa tell us
what year that that epidemic began epa
came back and said
that it was a 1989 that there's a red
line
oh
you know see so it's those diseases it's
also the allergic diseases which also
went epidemic in 89
diseases like food allergies peanut
allergies uh eczema anaphylaxis and
asthma and then the autoimmune diseases
suddenly became ubiquitous stuff we
never heard of as a kid juvenile
diabetes um rheumatoid arthritis lupus
graves disease crohn's disease uh
gianberry all of these
autoimmune injuries and
and um
you know and all of those incidentally
are listed as vaccine side effects
on the manufacturer's inserts
of the 72 vaccines that are not doses
that are not required for our children
so
and that's the one place where the
pharmaceutical companies tell the truth
because under the vaccine act you cannot
sue a vaccine company for injuring you
no matter how negligent they were no
matter how reckless they were
no matter how grievous your injury you
cannot sue them
the only exception to that is if they
knew of an injury that it's caused by
their vaccine and they failed to list it
on their manufacturer's insert
and so there are
420 injuries listed on the
manufacturer's insert
and by the way they're not allowed to
list them unless the fda believes that
that injury was caused by the vaccine or
that there is there's significant
scientific evidence that supports the
association
so um all of these you know the we now
have this chronic disease epidemic in
our country there's about 175 diseases
of chronic diseases that are now
epidemic
and every single one of them is listed
as a side effect on those 72 vaccine on
at least one of the 72 vaccines
doses
okay so in your view which of the
vaccines that are now given to children
are
are necessary
uh given the severity of the of the
disease it's preventing
versus the potential side effects
well you tell me what disease do you
consider a threat because i you know i
would say there's diseases that aren't
aren't even casually contagious that
most of the vaccines after 1989 were
added not for public health reasons but
for profit
pharmaceutical profit reasons so why are
we vaccinating
one day old babies for hepatitis b
when the only way they're going to get
hepatitis b
is
you know the hepatitis b is sexually
transmitted you got it from having sex
with you know with uh
from multiple partners and gay sex or
from sex workers
or intravenous drug use why would you
give that to a baby it's
clearly the only reason in fact merck
when it developed the drug was told by
fda and cdc we want you to develop this
for those vulnerable populations and the
populations when they didn't buy it
merck went back to the agencies and
saying you told us to develop this
vaccine nobody's buying it
and cdc said don't worry we'll just
recommend it for children we'll force
everybody to buy it
so that's how it got on the schedule
there's no medical justification it's
true that you can get hepatitis b from
an infected mother
but every mother in every hospital in
the united states is tested for
hepatitis b so you can identify the kids
who would benefit you don't give it mass
population y
i'd say
um
that the
uh uh you know the meningitis vaccine by
its own manufacturers insert the injury
rate the the risk for death
if you vaccinate every college kid in
this country with meningitis
vaccine by their own reckoning you will
kill more people from vaccine injuries
and are killed by the disease annually i
think there's maybe
12 or 15 people who die annually from
hepatitis b
i mean from meningitis um the rotavirus
vaccine is almost certainly killing more
kids and injuring really grievous
injuries to children than uh rotavirus
oh you know and and you know the
chickenpox why are we giving chickenpox
it's causing a shingles epidemic
shingles is 20 times as deadly as
chickenpox oh and we knew that and if
you go to
the euro you know the in most european
countries the chickenpox vaccine is
prohibited in europe if you go on in
your in the uk
if you go on the national health service
website and look up chickenpox they say
we're not going to give it in the uk
because it causes shingles epidemics and
that
of course
it's much more dangerous to get shingles
than it is chickenpox chickenpox you
know is harmless rash and
sub-therapeutic
and virtually everybody
but if they don't i mean but if you
don't but if you don't
if you don't get chicken chicken pox
when you're a kid and you don't get that
lifetime immunity
you're much more likely to get shingles
when it gets older and there's you know
there's lots of scientific data cdc's
own studies
and i'll give you the name of the author
gary goldman
predicted that if you go forward with
this vaccine you will have a shingles
epidemic and it will be more deadly than
chickenpox and that's exactly what
happened here and that's exactly why the
british don't do it
is that because you have you get the
vaccine and then the immunity wears off
potentially well here's what happens in
the natural population
kids would get chicken pox
usually that came in two year cycles
so kids would get chicken pox and they'd
have lifetime immunity
but
the lifetime immunity was dependent on
the kids get on the adults getting
periodically exposed to chickenpox
your exposure to children who had
chickenpox acted like a booster where
reactivated your own immunity
there were small numbers of people who
got shingles at that time but generally
speaking they were people who did not
have contact with children
when i was a kid shingles were
associated with a kind of grouchy old
curmudgeons of you know
older people who hated kids and we
didn't know nobody knew we didn't know
why
but those were the people who ended up
getting shingles and of course it made
them more pissed off when they got
shingles
um because very very painful and it also
can kill you and it could cause
blindness it's a really dangerous
disease
if you get that vaccine
the immunity wears off and you know
seven to ten years is gone for many from
i think a third or
fifty percent of the population
those people are now vulnerable to
adult chickenpox which is very dangerous
or shingles which is essentially is the
same as ostervirus
and you know i mean of course the the
vaccine companies love it because what
merck did is it's giving people
chickenpox shots
which makes a high level the population
then vulnerable shingles
and
in order to make the shingles vaccine it
just puts a double dose of the chicken
box in in one vial and gives you that
and say now you had a chicken a shingles
vaccine and it's cranking in money by
giving us the shingles
and by then
saving us from shingles so
it's a scam and you know we shouldn't be
surprised these pharmaceutical companies
are criminal enterprises the four
companies
that make all of our vaccines have paid
72
billion dollars in criminal penalties
since 2000 or
civil damages
are false find signs for lying to
regulators for bribing blackmailing
doctors these are the companies that
created the opioid crisis that they you
know merck gave us vioxx which killed a
hundred thousand americans at least
um
and you know and they did it knowing it
was going to cause heart attacks and
they didn't tell the public so these
companies are not companies we should
trust
and the only reason they got caught in
all those cases because the individual
plaintiffs attorneys like myself
representing individual clients who were
injured
recovered documents on discovery that
showed criminal conduct and then walked
them down to the u.s attorney's office
and said you should prosecute these
people because they're criminals
the only place that could ever happen is
vaccines
because you can't zoom so there's no
discovery there's no depositions there's
no class actions or multi-district
litigation they can get away with
anything they want forever
that's why it's so dangerous that's why
we need public scrutiny on this industry
because they are they are a rogue outlaw
industry
that is making and and you know listen
if they
if if they give you a measles vaccine
if i listen i and these were my kids i
had 11 brothers and sisters we all got
measles it was it was a great week we
stayed home we watched sea and you know
we got soup
what is the cure for measles the
treatment for measles
it's chicken soup and vitamin a you
can't patent those a pharma was seeing
all these people who were sick and
making no money
but if they give you a measles an mmr
vaccine
and now one in every couple thousand
people get the seizures and one in every
thousand of them now has lifetime
epilepsy
you now have a um a customer for life
who's paying a lot of money for chronic
disease every one of these childhood
diseases
pumps measles chicken pox were
self-limiting in other words after a
week they're gone
and they were all treatable
none of the chronic diseases that are
caused by vaccines are self-limiting
their lifetime injuries they're unsure
they're they're treatable the symptoms
are treatable but you're addicted you
ate now you have an uh a seven you know
like i'm buying for my kids
600 epipens for life
and albuterol inhalers
and you know adderall and all these
things that that we now are are this
generation is addicted to
because they've all got chronic disease
i'm not saying the vaccines are causing
all those chronic diseases because you
know our kids today are swimming around
in a toxic soup that we've created for
them and i don't just sue vaccine
companies
i assume monsanto and fluoride companies
and emfs
pfoas i'm suing monsanto for bfoas too
which is another you know suspect in the
chronic disease epidemic
neonicotinoid pesticides there's a whole
lot of culprits out there
that share the same timeline you've got
to find some environmental exposure that
began in 1989 that affected every
demographic
and suddenly
cuban kids and cheapest game miami have
chronic disease and autism and atd and
food allergies and at the same time
inuit in alaska
so it's easy to figure out which one
there's only a certain amount of
culprits we know it has to be an
environmental toxin because genes do not
cause epidemics they may provide the
vulnerability but you need an
environmental toxin so you need to
identify toxins that became ubiquitous
in 1989
i heard that
your
um i believe it was instagram was shut
down so why do you think that you are
being targeted
to i stop what you're saying and who do
you think is doing that
you know instagram said that i was
passing vaccine misinformation
but they were not able to identify a
single post i made that was ever
factually erroneous
and we have a huge fact-checking
operation at the children's health
defense we have on our advisory board
uh nobel prize winner luke montaner who
who discovered the hiv virus we have the
former head of the national toxicity
program we have
312
phd scientists and physicians we our
fact checking operation is run by lynn
redwood
who was an eight-year advisor to the
pentagon to hhs he was a public health
official in georgia
we do not
put
misinformation onto the public airwaves
or our internet and
instagram had to deny me the right that
it provided
donald trump who got to appeal
they had to stop me from appealing
because they had no justification for
evicting me from instagram the
term vaccine misinformation as they use
it is just a euphemism for any statement
that challenges official orthodoxies or
pharmaceutical or questions
pharmaceutical products if you've
questioned pharmaceutical products you
get shut down and censored
do you think that's
because of the general public i would
say believes that these products are
safe so it's going against the norm or
do you think that pharmaceutical
companies are involved in this somehow
of course the pharma is involved there's
a you know
look at who's profiting from this it's a
it's a coalition of
pharmaceutical companies of the internet
titans who are making billions and
billions from these government policies
from the lockdowns who had to you know
engineered a transfer wealth of 3.8
trillion dollars
from the middle classes globally
to a handful of super rich mainly
internet titans like bill gates like
larry ellis and like sergey brin google
oracle facebook
um you know the and and amazon you shut
down a million businesses who's going to
profit from that you lock people in the
home for the year who's going to profit
oh you know you look you ask the
question qui bono who is profiting and
that's how you can figure out who is you
know and they've been very open about
the same companies
that are profiting from the lockdown are
censoring
critics of the lockdown
and you know that
i think should
should uh inform people as to what's
happening in this country today
we've seen
a coup d'etat against democracy over the
past 20 months we've seen our
constitution obliterated and freedom of
speech of shutting down every church for
a year and keeping the liquor stores
open as essential businesses which i
have no problems with but
the churches are in the constitution not
the liquor stores and i'm not saying you
can't shut down a church if there's a
medical crisis
but you need to do it democratically you
need to have public hearings
you can do emergencies
but you know after
a week or two you need to have a public
hearing and you have to you need to show
the science that you're relying on and
you need people
to give the people the opportunity to
debate that science and to challenge it
and to bring their own science and we
need a public discussion
that's what democracy is and that's been
obliterated i got rid of jury trials
which are guaranteed in the sixth and
seventh amendment that no
american citizen shall be denied the
right
of a trial before a jury of his peers in
in cases or controversies exceeding 25
in value
is very simple there's no pandemic
exception there's no other exception
and yet jury trials have been abolished
for any corporation that claims to be
providing a countermeasure like a
vaccine you don't get to sue them they
do anything they want to you
destroy your life your livelihood
tell you unless you use this product you
can't work you can't send your kids to
school you can't go on public
transportation
and there's no public hearing
we don't get to challenge it oh you know
this is
a complete obliteration of
of constitutional governance
do you think it's possible that these
pharmaceutical companies set out to do
something like eradicate disease
and that
the side effects from vaccines
were an accident and these people aren't
actually aware of some of these dangers
well pfizer is aware of the dangers
because
eizer is right in the data
you know if i here's what pfizer's data
says either if eiser was supposed to do
a three-month a three-year clinical
trial and it was actually a good thing
because it was the first time
that a vaccine company had ever been
forced to do a pre-licensing clinical
trial and it was a big one it was 22 000
in the placebo group 22 000 in the
vaccine group
so
they shut it down at six months because
they saw the vaccine was waning vaccines
after six months you know we're seeing
now data all over the world that they'd
no longer give protection so they had to
shut it down in six months rather than
do the full three years
at six months they took the data to that
date they showed it to fda and they got
the license
why did they get the license they got
licensed because they were able to show
there was one of those 22 000 people
there was one death one death in the
vaccine group
and there were two deaths in the placebo
group
so they were able to make the claim the
vaccine is 100 effective because the
number two is 100 of the number one
most americans when they hear it's 100
effective against death
assume
they're they're thinking absolute risk
and if you get the vaccine you have 100
chance of not dying but that's not what
it said
what it said is you need to give 22 000
vaccines to save one life from covet
here's the really bad news
in the vaccine group
according to pfizer's data 20 people
died
in the placebo group in that six month
period of those twenty two 000 20 people
died
in the placebo group 14 died
so what that indicates is that your
chances of dying
if you're vaccinated are 48 greater than
if you're unvaccinated how are they
dying well here's what their advisors
data say
in the vaccine group
five people died from heart attacks
in the placebo group one person died of
a heart attack so if you get the vaccine
your 500 percent greater chance of dying
of a heart attack
and for every one life they say from
govid
they're killing four people from heart
attacks
eiser knows this it's their data the
table is called s4
anybody who's watching this can look it
up
and so you can't say that fuzzer doesn't
know that it is
causing public health havoc right now
with this product and you know we're
seeing
these explosions on theirs the biggest
you know where this vaccine has had
more deaths reported
in the last year then during
35 years of the existence of the system
all put together from billions and
billions and billions of vaccines we're
seeing these death rates that are off
the
charts and
um and we also know that only that
probably fewer than one percent of those
deaths are actually being reported most
people who have a parent who dies a
month or a few weeks after vaccination
is not reporting into theirs
very few too according to
hhs's own study
fewer than one percent of vaccine deaths
are reported
yeah okay so
what are your views on
on um giving this covid vaccine that
they've made to kids i know i'm from
canada and i i think that they're
implementing that in order to go to
school in canada
well they have to give it to kids
because
here's why
they
they cannot market this vaccine without
having immunity shield
oh i mean i sue pharmaceutical companies
for a living
and i have enough criminal activity that
i know about pfizer at this point and
moderna
that if they went ahead and marketed a
vaccine where i where they can where
they end up killing people or injuring
them
and i consume them
or they'd be thrilled so they're never
going to market a vaccine
allow people access to a vaccine an
approved vaccine
without getting liability protect and
now the the emergency use authorization
vaccines
have liability protection under the prep
act and the care sector so as long as
you take an emergency use
you can't sue them
once they get approved
now you consume
unless
they can get it recommended for children
what
because all vaccines that are
recommended officially recommended for
children get
liability protection even if an adult
gets that vaccine
that's why they're going after kids they
know this is going to kill and injure a
huge number of children
but they need to do it for the liability
protection and here's how they know that
it's going to injure kids
during the pfizer study
they only tested it on 300 children
and one of those we now know was a girl
called maddie gary
and we only know about this
because she and her family came forward
and told them what told us what happened
maddie gary got the vaccine she
immediately went into seizures she is
now in a wheelchair for life and she
needs a feeding tube to eat
oh
five or five you know because flies are
only 10 1300 kids it is stuck
with the
with the
extrapolation
and one out of every 1300 kids is going
to be injured like that an injury worse
than death
pfizer did not report her injury
instead it said she had a stomachache so
that's what they reported to the fda
they lied
and they know that
that this
here's what the lancet study showed
a lancet study showed that
lancet could not the researchers could
not find a single
child in the world who die a healthy
child who died from covet
there are many children who died but you
know not a lot i think the uk had only
like 25 um confirmed pcr confirmed covet
as in children
we in this country we had under 400
but all of those children had severe
comorbidities most of them were
really extremely obese and had diabetes
asthma and a lot of other camera
abilities healthy kids do not die from
coving
so why would you give them an
intervention that we know can kill them
that is causing myocarditis and death in
children all over the world right now we
know that why would you ever give a
child that intervention you're not doing
it for the child
there's no pretense
it's going to help that child
and what they'll say is we're giving it
to him so he doesn't get granny sick but
there's no evidence
and
children tend to internalize this
disease they're not coughing and you
know and sneezing with it it tends to
they tend to internalize it there's no
evidence that they're passing it to
anybody and anyway there's a big ethical
problem of saving of killing a kid or
or putting a child at risk to save a
very old person there's an ethical
dilemma there that people need to be
talking about
but
if there's no
argument that you're giving this to the
child for his own health
you're giving it to the child i mean the
real reason that you know to me is
obvious
i can't read minds but you know having
written
this book and having studied the
pharmaceutical industry for 18 years
um it's pretty evident that the their
rationale for giving it to kids is they
need the liability protection and you
can only get that if you mandate it for
children if you know
fizer did get
an authorization a license
to sell
its vaccine in the united states but
what it did is a trick it it created a
new vaccine out of the same vaccine so
the same file it put a different label
on it and called it the commentary
and the one that got approved is the one
with the commonality label although it's
identical to the bio and tech vaccine
that we're all taking which is emergency
use authorization
the commonality they will not make it
available to americans why
because you consume them
and so
it's the only one approved
and they will not sell it here because
we consume
what they're waiting for is approved
for children
and as soon as it gets mandated for
children now they have liability
protection and they'll give it to their
estimates and we won't be able to sue
them
and which vaccine is that
this is the pfizer vaccine
the pfizer vaccine is not there there's
an approved version and there another
there's an emergency youth version
it and they're identical i see okay
one different label and that one with
that label is the only one that is
approved but you cannot get it in our
country because they're not going to
allow an american to get it because if
you get it you consume them
can you get it in other countries
i think you can get it in europe they
have other liability protection over
there which i'm not familiar with
so um you mentioned that the vaccines
you thought were the most dangerous were
ones with aluminum in them one why is
there aluminum in there in the first
place and two what kind of danger would
that pose to people
well
here's you know
in the history of vaccinology vaccines
originally
were all live virus vaccines so the
polio vaccine was live virus and you
know the small box was like virus what
they found is that if you give somebody
a live virus vaccine is
a mutation the virus that is less deadly
so you give the people you make them a
little bit sick and they get the
lifetime immunity
that was the theory
the problem is the viruses were
oftentimes mutating inside of the person
and then the you know through their
urine or their fever their mainly their
feces
the the mutated version would would
develop more pathogenicity more
virulence and would spread so today 70
of the polio cases in the world
are vaccine strain they're coming from
vaccinated individuals vaccinated
individuals can shed the virus and
infect other people
so the regulatory agencies early on
uh expressed a preference for dead virus
vaccines the problem is the dead virus
vaccines do not provoke the same
robust durable antibody response
and in fact synology in order to get a
license you need to show that the
vaccine lasts a certain amount of time
and that it is you know it has a
powerful antibody response
a vaccinologist
discovered early on that if they if they
add an ingredient to the vaccine that is
horrendously toxic
that
the body associates that toxic material
with the
viral antigen
and the next time it sees that antigen
it will mount a robust immune response
and there's a saying a mantra in
vaccinology that the more toxic the
adjuvant the more robust the response
so there was a search among
vaccinologists and virologists around
the globe
for the most toxic elements in the
universe
to add to vaccines
and to provoke these responses and you
know they they want aluminum i mean
mercury was a very very um
ubiquitous
addition they put it in they say it was
preservative but it didn't act as a
preservative it was really there as an
advent and nih admitted that to us
the mercury is the most toxic element in
the universe known to man that is not
radioactive so it's a thousand what
times more neurotoxic than lead why
would you would you ever dream of
injecting your child with lead well
you're injecting them with something
that is a thousand times worse than lead
and mercury was removed from
most american vaccines except for the
flu vaccine
in 2003
and
they needed to replace another
you know the mercury was not something
else that was horribly toxic so they use
aluminum
the problem is with accidentology it
says they don't look at chronic disease
and they don't they they don't know
anything about toxicology
oh
you know and they don't like
toxicologists because the toxicologists
would come in and say
yeah it that
that aluminum is making the vaccine last
longer the the you know the anti-body
effect of the vaccine
lasts longer but what's happening to the
aluminum in your body
you know what is the fate of it is it
being excreted
or
is it going to your organs and
particularly to your brain
and as it turns out that's exactly what
it's doing it's going to your brain
and it's staying in your brain for
decades and causing inflammation
and we know this because there's a
series of studies that nih did during
the 80s and one of them particularly by
thomas burbacker but there's many many
other studies that are
that show that the aluminum i mean there
are studies by chris shaw and chris
ecksley who are kind of the world's
experts on aluminum toxicity looking at
the brains of children
who have
autism and other neurological diseases
and finding that they're loaded with
mercury
with aluminum
and that the aluminum is um you know at
levels you see in an adult with
alzheimer's in the cadavers of an adult
with alzheimer's i looked at i think 10
kids uh
cadavers and and found this here's
something that people should know
is that
aluminum provokes an allergic response
and that's why it's valuable so if you
put the aluminum in with the viral
antigen your body now mounts an allergic
response to that viral antigen whether
it's polio or
hepatitis b or the you know hpp or
whatever
so but
what we now know
the science suggests
is that the aluminum also
creates allergic responses to anything
that's in the ambient environment
so if you have a peanut oil excipient in
that vaccine
you and you put aluminum in it how you
could have a lifetime allergy to peanuts
if you if there's a timothy weed
outbreak
that the weekly you get that aluminum
vaccine
you now may have a lifetime allergy to
timothy weed and that's why probably you
know there's two studies by moss and
cowlings
which oh that children who
are vaccinated with aluminum vaccines
have 30 times the rate of allergic
rhinitis as kids who don't
and you know all of these um these food
allergy epidemics
date to the time that we started giving
these kids this aluminum and
because my kids have these allergies i'm
one of the founders of the food allergy
initiative in the food allergy network
which is the biggest food allergy
research group and what you know so
that group has scientists from all over
the world who are giving food allergies
to rats
and then
figuring out how to treat them
how do they give the allergy to the rat
they take the aluminum
from the adjuvant from hepatitis b
vaccine
add a latex
molecule and that right now is a
permanent latex allergy you add a peanut
molecule and it has a permanent peanut
allergy you add a dairy molecule now has
a permanent dairy allergy
you wonder why all of this whole
generation of children is allergic to
stuff
it's because we've been inducing
allergies by pumping them full of
aluminum
that's great that's crazy yeah
thank you very very much for coming on
thank you very much for coming on
yeah i hope you won't edit out my best
arguments i won't edit anything this
entire thing is going up
well i want to see what they do to you
thank you very much miguel
thank you very much for coming on bye
okay this is awesome i'm doing
investments for dad and this one is
really cool investing in fine art i
recently learned that top earners
allocate around 20 of their wealth into
just one asset class with inflation at a
39-year high and with no signs of
stopping on top of covet variants
affecting the stock market it's pretty
good time to rethink what you invest in
and one of the smartest ways to
diversify your portfolio
is by investing in fine art this is a
really cool idea i think most people can
get behind i hadn't heard of it before
maybe you've never thought about it but
the one percent have been doing this for
generations the art market which the
wall street journals called one of the
hottest on earth today is projected to
be worth 2.7 trillion by 2026 which
means when the markets crash and stock
prices go berserk like they have been
since the pandemic started art prices
continue to surge and you no longer have
to be an a-list celebrity to invest in
million dollar works of art masterworks
is the first and only fintech company
that securitizes blue chip artwork from
artists like warhol banksy so anyone can
invest in multi-million dollar paintings
at an affordable entry point
for example the first painting
masterwork sold was banksy's mona lisa
for 1.5 million and that went on to get
investors a 32 net annualized return
over 260 000 investors are already doing
it
if you want to check it out visit
masterworks dot art
mp today again that's masterworks dot
art slash mp see important disclaimers
at masterworks dot io slash disclaimer
enjoy the rest of the episode
amish adalga welcome to my podcast
thanks for having me
before we get started can you give a
brief background about who you are and
what it is you do
sure so i'm a senior scholar at the
johns hopkins center for health security
which is a public health think tank
focused on emerging infectious diseases
biosecurity bioterrorism the
intersection of infectious disease and
national security as well as pandemic
preparedness i'm also a practicing
infectious disease critical care and
emergency medicine physician and taking
care of patients throughout this
pandemic and i do a lot of media and
public speaking on these topics as well
okay great so this format of episode um
i had somebody on who has who's
skeptical of vaccines you could say that
to say the least so i'm having you on to
i like
with your background to describe
vaccines in the ways well you believe
they should be described
so should be a good conversation i'm
going to ask you a whole bunch of
questions
uh so let's go
uh
just vaccines in general vaccines that
are given to children do you believe any
of them are dangerous in in any way
that people aren't aware of
not really so when you look at any
vaccine there's always a risk benefit
calculation you have to make that there
are risks of the vaccine there are risks
of the disease that you're preventing
but when you look at the vaccines that
are used in routine childhood
immunization in western countries they
are very very safe vaccines and the
diseases that they're preventing
really have risks that are
higher than the risks from the vaccine
there's always changes and updates made
based on different prevalences of
infections and different vaccines that
may be developed but what you're getting
as a child now is a a
group of very safe vaccines that have
been proven to be effective and really
uh have a great benefit to the
individual child being vaccined
okay so something that came up with the
last guy i spoke with was the hep b
vaccine he said america has
gives out more vaccinations to children
than anywhere on earth
and that's but that's a good thing i
would say that's a good thing yeah
yeah yeah fair enough fair enough um but
one vaccine in particular and i didn't
know this the hep b vaccine so can you
describe can you explain why that would
be given to somebody that's so young
like somebody who's one day old as
opposed to waiting a little bit longer
so hepatitis b is a major cause of liver
cancer around the world it causes acute
liver inflammation it can kill people
and we have really great hepatitis b
vaccines and initially those were given
to people that were high risk because
maybe they were injection drug users or
they got blood transfusions or they
worked in the healthcare industry or
they were commercial sex workers
based on the way that hepatitis b
transmits and what we saw is that there
were really
still major gaps in uptake of the
vaccine and what
studies showed was giving the vaccine
early on at birth increases the rate of
uptake and what we've seen is this safe
and effective vaccine given to newborns
ended up translating to lower hepatitis
b rates throughout lifetime and through
in the country so the reason why they
give that vaccine isn't because the
two-day-old is at risk for getting
hepatitis b although they could get it
from a mother their mother
it's because when you give the vaccine
at that point it ensures that they
actually get vaccinated because we saw
drop-offs even if you say maybe don't
get it
before you leave the hospital but get it
at your first child your child
pediatricians your child's pediatrician
visit we saw a drop-off and that
translated into more hepatitis b cases
so that's why the recommendation came to
give this vaccine to babies before they
leave the hospital because it ensured
that they got the vaccine and we saw
actual benefits in terms of hepatitis b
risk and cases based on changing the
policy to recommend it before people
leave the hospital
so then why not give some of these other
vaccines earlier
because vaccines are not given
arbitrarily they have to be given at
certain times based on the immune system
based on uh other things that are going
on and for many vaccines if you give
them too early and this isn't the case
with hepatitis b the maternal antibodies
that that the child is exposed to
through the placenta will interfere with
the vaccine so for example if you give
an influenza vaccine to a child below
the age of six months a lot of that
vaccine won't really actually do
anything because there's so much
maternal influenza antibody that
basically mop up the vaccine the same is
true for the the measles mumps rubella
so we tend to wait until the antibodies
fall
and that's when we give the give the
vaccines but we there's always a little
bit of latitude when the best time to
give the vaccines are but it is based on
the immune system of the developing
child as well as the epidemiology of the
infection
okay and so then why not is it safer to
wait longer then because i've heard from
people who are more skeptical of
vaccines that the younger you give it
the harder it is neurologically but in
like as opposed to waiting till children
are say five or something like that
there's no evidence so there's no
evidence to support that waiting longer
changes anything with the safety profile
i think this is something that is
misunderstood
you should get the vaccine when when
it's the appropriate time to get the
vaccine and they have been proven to be
safe and effective at the time that
you're giving them and there's no
evidence that delaying the vaccine
somehow increases the safety when the
vaccine is
is needed at a certain period of time or
has been studied in that certain time
period i think it's sort of arbitrary to
say maybe if we give it later it might
work better but it could be the other
way around it could also work less well
when you give it later or it could not
or could have more side effects when it
works later i think that people don't
really understand that these aren't just
kind of
people throwing a dart at a timeline and
saying this is what we're going to give
you the vaccine they actually think
about when the optimal time to give it
is
okay
is it true that there are no
in order to get a vaccine tested they
don't do double-blind studies or is that
not true
that's not true um for example the
cova-19 vaccines these were
double-blind placebo-controlled studies
where people didn't know if they were
getting an innocuous substance injected
into them or
the coven-19 vaccine so double-blind
controlled trials are the gold standard
for for vaccine trials and for trials of
any other type of medication
is that just for the vaccine for covid
or is that for other vaccines as well
other vaccines are are studied in double
blind there's multiple different trial
designs the the gold standard is
double-blind placebo-controlled trials
sometimes we do head-to-head trials with
two different types of vaccines if there
are two competitors out there or or an
improved vaccine but the double-blind
controlled trial is what's used for the
initial approval of
virtually all vaccines to my knowledge
okay
here's another concern that's frequently
brought up aluminum and vaccines as the
adjuvant is there evidence that that
either accumulates in tissues or that
that's toxic in other ways or that it
links people to allergens in the
environment while you're provoking an
immune response to whatever
disease you're being vaccinated against
there's no evidence that aluminum as an
adjuvant is harmful actually aluminum as
an adjuvant is helpful we put aluminum
in vaccines so they actually stimulate
your immune system in a more strong
fashion to give you more protection i
actually wish our vaccines had more
adjuvants in them but sometimes people
don't like the the feeling after an
adjuvant because it does make your arm a
little bit sore if you get an adjuvant
vaccine but no there's no evidence that
the currently used adjuvants have any
major problem especially not
aluminum which is one of the more widely
used used um adjuvants but in general
you have to remember that it's not like
people are giving adjuvants in order to
try and
harm somebody with them the adjuvant is
there because they're trying to make the
vaccine more effective adjuvants are an
important tool that we use
is it possible though that by adding an
adjuvant
people exposed to other allergens
while they're being vaccinated could end
up with
allergies to whatever that other
allergen is like the uprising peanuts or
or egg whites i had this this and this
could be completely off
and i'm totally aware of that but i know
that
there were i believe it was egg whites
added to vaccines to trigger an immune
response and i know there was an uptick
in egg allergens allergies an uptick in
peanut allergies soy allergies i'm
wondering if that has any link between
the increase in vaccination for children
i don't think there's any strong
evidence to support that and it's
important remember like when you look at
aluminum remember you get tons of
aluminum in your normal diet it's the
amount that's in a vaccine is much less
than what you're ingesting
or getting exposed to in the environment
there
there have been reactions to certain
adjuvants in in the past that that have
precluded their use or have questions
for example during the pandemic of h1n1
in 2009 there were some adjuvanted
vaccines that have somewhat been linked
to narcolepsy that hasn't been fully um
proven but it was a signal and i think
people are cautious about those
adjuvants in certain situations but in
general uh
remember that you're we're talking about
risk benefit ratios and what you're
trying to protect against and i think
that all in all adjuvants and vaccines
are an improvement on
on vaccines and there isn't any clear
indication that they that they provoke
or cause allergies although there have
been reactions to adjuvants like i
mentioned with narcolepsy and certain in
certain pandemic h1n1 vaccines and
certain adjuvants definitely make your
arm hurt you get more reactogenic but
that's sort of part of the adjuvant
working but but in general i think that
the more adjustments we had in vaccines
the more effective our vaccines would be
the less we would need boosters the less
we would
have to worry about breakthrough
infections with whatever it might be
uh just out of curiosity what was the
adjuvant that's potentially linked to
narcolepsy although you said that wasn't
proven just out of curiosity
the adjuvant that was
suspected to be involved with narcolepsy
is something called aso3
which is kind of an oil and oil and
water emulsion adjuvant is what it's
described as that's the one where there
was uh some
some hint that narcolepsy might have
been more common in people who receive
vaccines containing that adjuvant but
that was something that our safety
systems detected and quickly have been
trying to run down and understand
understand it wasn't something that was
uh
not well known this was something that
was clear
when um
when that signal was identified
and did they identify that before the
vaccine went out
no this was something that they had seen
anecdotally reported after the vaccine
was was um used it wasn't used in every
country so for example the united states
that that type of vaccine wasn't used
but it was used in places like canada um
and it was picked up with the safety
signal saying that there had been some
some cases of narcolepsy
and this is still something that isn't
completely understood why this happened
or or what type of signal it was and i
think it's still an area of active
investigation of narcolepsy linked to
some of these pandemic vaccines because
there hadn't been
that
in the past
this with that measurement
what happened with that
and in that side effect i think it's
still something that is a correlation
signal but not something that i would
say has been definitively unraveled
okay that makes sense um
in regards to the covid vaccine
specifically
i was told and i haven't done any
background research on this so i'm not
sure what's right here but i'm i was
told that in the pfizer vaccine trial
group
20 people died versus the placebo group
where 14 people died have you heard
anything about this
i don't think that that's accurate
representation
when we look at what happened in that
first of all when you look at you have
to understand what the cause of death
what the cause of deaths were are they
related to the treatment first of all
and i think that those raw numbers are
wrong i think when you look at the the
pfizer the pfizer date and i don't have
it memorized to be able to quote it off
the top of my head i i've seen no such
signal like that and when you look at
where the covet 19 cases occurred it was
almost exclusively in the placebo group
and there wasn't really any imbalance in
deaths that that is concerning i think
that the pfizer vaccine even beyond the
clinical trial has really proven its
ability to to save lives and i don't
think that that's an accurate
representation of of where the of what
deaths occurred but remember even just
looking at raw numbers of deaths in a
trial you have to understand that people
are still especially when you're
vaccinating higher risk people or you're
vaccinating people that might have other
conditions that there may be other
diseases that that may cause them to
succumb which might cause deaths in the
in a treatment group in any clinical
trial that are unrelated to the
treatment but i don't think that those
numbers seem to be accurate to me but i
don't have those that that trial data
right in front of me to be able to um
to actually address it specifically
uh the concern i've heard was that okay
so and i think you people read about
this in the news is that the vaccine can
potentially cause some sort of heart
problem
and so in the pfizer study more people
died of heart attacks in the vaccine
group than they did in the placebo group
so then you have people saying okay it
can increase your risk of a heart attack
so it's not
death by covid but it's still an
associated death
so the heart conditions that people are
talking about with cover 19 vaccines are
not heart attacks it's something called
myocarditis which is different it's
heart inflammation and when you look at
those myocarditis cases they tend to be
very mild and not uh leading to death
whereas when you look at covariate 19
and it's linked to heart attacks uh we
see that there is kind of a synergy
between cover 19 and and coronary artery
disease and in heart in heart attacks
that have occurred so i don't think that
that the myocarditis or these side
effects people are talking about and
there is a signal from myocarditis with
the pfizer and modern vaccines primarily
in boys that are in their late teen
years to early adulthood
that's not a heart attack and that's not
really something that
to me changes the risk benefit
ratio of the vaccine because those
myocarditis cases tend to be mild they
tend to be something that's reversible
and
and the the rate of myocarditis that
occurs from the vaccine is much lower
than the rate of myocarditis that occurs
postcovid
that's a good point
post coping
um
do you think it's worth mandating that
people below the age of 18
need to get these covet vaccines
so when you use the word mandate it's
important to kind of unpack it
mandate can mean many things you know is
it something that schools want to
require as a condition of enrollment is
it something that a sports team or a
sports league wants to have
for kids to participate in that sport or
is it something that government is
actually saying this needs to be done as
a condition of life and i think that
it's important to
because people lump all of those
together because to me a mandate would
be something
a true mandate would be something that
the government actually says and no i
don't think that the government should
mandate the vaccine for people that are
under the ages of 18. i think if schools
want to do that as a condition of
enrollment that's perfectly fine and i
would say that that's that's a
reasonable decision to make if
organizations want to do that uh for
example for kids to participate in
something i think that's something
that's that can be done but i don't
think it should be the government uh
making that decision um to make demanded
i think this is something that private
private organizations can do it's a
little bit modeled because governments
control private private institutions
like what would be private institutions
and in some situations like schools um
but i think in in general no i don't
think it should be a government mandate
that children under the age of children
be be vaccinated and i think in general
government mandates
for vaccination are probably not are not
the way to do this i think private
organizations are are much better suited
to do this and it's a much
cleaner way of actually getting vaccine
vaccine uptake higher is to have private
businesses do it because it's in their
interest to do so rather than it being
something that the government requires
of people
is it true that if you do end up
if you do end up vaccine injured which
can be rare but if that does happen that
there's nothing you can really do about
it in regards to suing vaccine companies
this differs depending upon the country
that you're in but in the united states
they have a separate system uh which is
called the these there was this they're
called vaccine courts
there's a vaccine injury compensation
fund so when you get a vaccine or you
buy a vaccine there's a tax on it and
that is put towards this fund so when
you do have a vaccine injury you can
bring that claim to the vaccine court
and they adjudicate that to see whether
or not there is a possible link between
the vaccine and whatever injury and then
there is a payout from that vaccine
injury compensation fund that exists so
this was something that was set up
during the reagan administration as a
way to
encourage companies to get involved in
vaccines because vaccines are
controversial they've been controversial
since they were first invented in the
late 1700s and many pharmaceutical
companies said they didn't even want to
get involved in vaccines or they were
pulling out because it was such a
litigious area
and that would be really bad for all of
us if companies didn't want to make
vaccines we've had shortages of flu
vaccines and tetanus vaccines and and i
think that's not the situation we want
to have where where companies are not
wanting to do it so what was offered as
a solution was an alternative court
system with this injury compensation
fund
bring those injury claims to that court
so it's not as if you have no recourse
if you do get injured by a vaccine there
is a whole separate process put in place
because
for that exact reason so i think this is
sort of
a mistaken idea that it's not as if
you're just
have not nothing to do if you've if
you've been actually legitimately
injured by a vaccine there is a whole
system in place to be able to handle
those claims
okay that's interesting i didn't know
that but then you can't do it the
regular way where you can sue a company
no it's it's something separate when
depending upon the vaccine depending
upon there's certain criteria for which
which claims are are used in that
corporate but that's that's basically an
alternative system an alternative court
system an alternative legal framework
that's used for vaccines in the united
states
rather than bringing lawsuits directly
in
in normal court this is a whole separate
system that we have in order to to kind
of kind of streamline it to have expert
expert access and to
have this fund
where people can have
can get payouts based on on whatever
injury is so it's it's it's a parallel
system that i think has worked um
although i think it's it's widely
misunderstood
yeah that's interesting
so it was
potentially set up by the reagan
administration
to encourage pharmaceutical companies to
invest and make
vaccines without
necessarily feeling
like they would be sued repeatedly that
it was too dangerous of a
i guess a mission to go on right so if
you if you're if you're a pharmaceutical
company and you're looking at what do i
want to invest in what do i want to make
i mean vaccines are never at the top of
this in general infectious disease
products are never at the top of the
list and with vaccines because of the
rise of of anti-vaccine sentiment
because of because of the way vaccines
have kind of been engulfed into kind of
cultural wars
you find that many companies that's the
last thing that they want to get
involved in because they're so
controversial and what we were seeing
were many vaccine manufacturers
traditional vaccine manufacturers kind
of pulling out saying this isn't
something we're going to really invest
in and that would and that alarmed a lot
of people because if we don't have
people that are adept at making vaccines
we're really going to be at a higher
threat for many infectious diseases this
was one way to make it make it um much
more feasible for these companies to be
able to produce their products
in a manner where they weren't really
worried about the the downside loss for
or all of the lawsuits kind of piling up
that they'd have to deal with on a
one-by-one basis
and that's why this whole alternative
system was was set up in the 1980s
hmm that's interesting
you can see how people can get
conspiratorial when things like that
happen
where they're like oh you know they
can't be sued like they're immune so
they can go out there and potentially
harm you
and nobody can do anything about it
because they have a separate you know
court
you can
you can look at that court and see how
much money they paid out and what
they've actually
determined was a vaccine injury versus
what wasn't and i think it has worked it
has worked well because the interesting
thing is on the other side of this the
anti-vaccine people will often cite the
payouts as a way to show that vaccines
aren't safe saying you know the vaccine
injury court has paid out this much
money that means that these vaccines are
not not safe where
on the one hand they say that on the
other hand they say
you can't you have no recourse if you
have a vaccine injury so they can't
really have it both ways and i think uh
it's important just to put that on the
record that this this whole system
exists um
in order to deal with the rare vaccine
injuries that occur
yeah
okay
why do you think and what have you seen
with your public talks why do you think
there's so much anti-vaccine sentiment
well there's always been anti-vaccine
sentiment i think what's happened is
we've got a particularly virulent form
of it lately so when edward jenner
invented the first vaccine the vaccine
against smallpox that's when the
anti-vaccine movement was born if you
look at the cartoons from the newspapers
at that time they were mocking him and
saying that people were going to turn
into cows if they took this vaccine and
the same thing has kind of been true
with every new vaccine that there's been
opposition but what i would say has
accelerated is that
with the allegations in the 1990s um
regarding which were disproved and and
shown to be completely fallacious uh
regarding autism the anti-vaccine
movement took on a kind of a new
strength
and they've been emboldened by celebrity
culture where you've got multiple
celebrities that sometimes will voice
this and
and i think that people
also have
i think that maybe some people have kind
of turned against science and scientific
knowledge because when you look for
example at the way people are against
gmos for example where there's really no
strong evidence that gmos or genetically
modified organisms cause problems that's
that that same kind of precautionary
principle why should we put something
unnatural into our body that i think has
kind of spilled into people's thoughts
about vaccines
and we live in 2021
in most of the of the western world in a
in a place where we don't have to think
about deaths from measles or deaths from
diarrhea or pediatric pneumonia deaths
so you kind of have that luxury so it's
all out of sight out of mind
and i think that they don't realize
what the vaccines have done the lives
they've saved the infections that they
didn't caught that didn't happen that's
people are kind of blind to that because
it's not something they think about
anymore and thankfully they don't have
to think about it because because of the
work that vaccines have done so that
makes you think well
i heard so-and-so's kid had some problem
after they got this vaccine and there's
not been a measles case in this county
for so long why should i get this for
example they might say so they they kind
of get that anecdotal thinking about
these vaccine injuries they hear about
and then they don't see the other side
of that the measles cases that don't
happen or the kids with with chickenpox
that get hospitalized or or people who
with with polio so then they think well
why should i need it it's not really
an issue and i think that's kind of that
kind of sloppy thinking has really
become very very common and then you
have the the way that people have used
vaccines as part of these culture wars
to to cater to whatever collective tribe
that they might be trying to um
to uh
engender themselves to or to ingratiate
themselves to and i think they use
to me i always say it's like it's this
voice of the dark ages against science
that uses 21st century tools
to broadcast their message and i think
that's what's really scary now because
the anti-vaccine movement has really
grown in its influence
they are very proactive
and most of us in the medical community
are very reactive and i think they have
been winning because we haven't been
able to really
articulate the case for vaccines in a in
a forceful proactive way we're often
just kind of responding to one
conspiracy theory after another
conspiracy theory
and it's become a situation where
people who are pro-vaccine sometimes run
scared i mean i've been admonished at
hospitals i work at for being two
pro-vaccine
where we the pro-vaccine
the pro-vaccine physicians get
nasty emails and death threats and
threats of violence almost on a daily
basis now
this is i think a really bad sign
because to me vaccines and their benefit
are incontrovertible i tell people you
know everybody clamors for a new iphone
they all wait in line to get a new
iphone that's how i think people should
think about vaccines this is some great
new piece of technology that's going to
improve my life allow me to live better
and you should want that um they used to
have ticker tape parades when i'm
talking to you now from pittsburgh which
is my hometown and this is where the
polio vaccine was
uh invented by jonas salk when he came
back after the announcement of the
results to pittsburgh he had to have a
police escort and there were ticker tape
parades and people putting up signs in
the window saying thank you dr salk
that's not how we greet new vaccines now
a new vaccine is not greeted the way dr
salk was greeted a new vaccine is
greeted with conspiracy theories i think
about the way the hpv that gardasil
vaccine which prevents cervical cancer
how that was greeted not like the polio
vaccine and i think that really speaks
to something that's wrong in our culture
in in some loss of respect for science
that i think we're all going to pay for
and we are paying for it with the low
uptake of coba 19 vaccines for example
in the united states
i think people are confused for a number
of reasons
i mean even i'm confused what i would
say one like the rate of
disease in children has skyrocketed in
the last like 30 years
and i was diagnosed with juvenile
rheumatoid arthritis as a child so i've
spent my life and i have it in remission
now thank goodness but uh i've spent my
time kind of thinking why
right and so then if you're in put in
that position you kind of look
everywhere like i've gone you know way
out there to try and figure out why this
could happen and i don't know if i'll
ever figure it out but i think you end
up with a population of people who are
saying okay well we've been listening to
pharmaceutical companies
um and everyone's sicker like
so
yeah we're not getting measles anymore
but the rate of autoimmune disorders are
up or mental illness and neurological
disorders are up and so people start
maybe
incorrectly associating the two or
associating that with anything newer
it's interesting that they don't like
one of this is actually an area where
there's a lot of hypotheses about why
allergies why autoimmune conditions have
went up and
one of the things that i think needs
more
uh study is the overuse of antibiotics
because like while you say that vaccines
have gone up the use of antibiotics for
for all kinds of upper respiratory tract
infections inappropriate antibiotic use
correlates very strongly with allergy
with asthma with autism with childhood
obesity so so there may there is a
signal there but i don't think it's
vaccines that are the problem i think
it's inappropriate use of antibiotics
and think about how many antibiotic
courses people get now um as a child as
the child for maybe viral ear infections
or viral coughs that i think is
something that really needs to be
addressed and i think that vaccines are
getting blamed for something that that's
probably not that's probably more
related or likely to be related to
overuse of antibiotics than anything
interesting okay yeah i've looked into
that i was on antibiotics constantly as
a kid
that could have contributed to it i
think some of the skepticism comes from
confusion about this
specific covid vaccine so you hear about
the polio vaccine and i'm not entirely
you could actually describe what that
looked like when you got vaccinated but
from what i know you got the vaccine you
had a bit of a reaction and then you
never got polio
and that's not what we're seeing with
coven people are like wow the vaccine
doesn't work it's not like the polio
vaccine it's not like these other
vaccines so it doesn't work you have to
keep getting it this entire thing is a
scam then you go down that route so
maybe you could address that a bit
but when you think about vaccines
they're they're tasked with doing
different things based on the disease
and what's going on and not every
vaccine produces what's called
sterilizing immunity meaning is like a
force field around you so you don't get
infected and with these first generation
coveted vaccines our goal was
not to prevent every infection
but to prevent serious disease
hospitalization and death and by that
standard they're performing off the
charts there may be second generation
vaccines down the line that work more
like the measles vaccine but we don't
have those yet and i think it's
important to judge these vaccines based
on what they were actually designed to
do and and by that standard as i said um
they're some of the most successful
vaccines we've seen and you can just
open your eyes if you walk through the
hospital and see who's getting who's
getting hospitalized who's dying and
i'll be taking care of patients with
covet tomorrow and
it's going to be primarily unvaccinated
people yes breakthrough infections occur
but they're very rare and when the
severe ones are even rarer and that's
actually evidence of the vaccine working
not that it's failing or that it's some
kind of scam because we weren't we
weren't trying with these first
generation vaccines to be able to to
create a bug zapper around you so that
no virus got on you
the the idea was to make this a tamer
virus one that's much more like other
viruses and think about the flu vaccine
flu vaccine breakthrough infections
occur all the time but we know for
example look at pediatric deaths and flu
the vast majority of children who die
from flu are not vaccinated so the flu
vaccine's goal is not to prevent every
infection but to prevent serious disease
hospitalization and death and many
people accept that about the flu vaccine
not every vaccine does the same thing
and not that we don't have the same goal
with every infectious disease and it's
important to remember that because covet
19 is not something that can be
eradicated or eliminated we're going to
have covar cases 20 years from now the
goal is to make it much more manageable
and that's what these first generation
vaccines do
and so i think that that's a misplaced
idea that somehow kova can become like
measles it can't uh cova can't become
like polio these are different types of
viruses with different biological
characteristics and covid comes from a
family of viruses that cause 25 of our
common colds
so this is going to become a seasonal
corona virus a seasonal cold virus and
the goal is to tame it by getting more
people immune to it to its serious
effects and that's what the vaccine is
in the safest man possible
is it necessary for people who've
already had covet to get vaccinated say
you've had coveted twice
so what we know is that natural immunity
is something that's real it does protect
you against reinfection especially in
the early months after you're in after
your initial bout with the virus it
probably does protect you from getting
serious illness but the problem with
natural immunity
or and i don't like the word natural
immunity because all immunity you can
get immunity from the vaccine too that's
natural as well but the immunity from
prior infection we don't know how robust
it is in terms of how long it lasts how
predictable it is because some people
have very high immunity after infection
some people have very low and its
ability to fend off some of the variants
has been called into question uh
specifically with the south african
variant which was the beta variant so
what i recommend is that people who've
had prior infection just get a single
dose of vaccine that's enough to top off
your immunity to make you probably one
of the more immune people on the planet
against coban 19 and i think this is
something that should be put into the
guidelines uh it is in guidelines in
places like israel but it's not in the
u.s guidelines i don't think it's in the
canadian guidelines but there is a
single dose johnson johnson vaccine that
is available that i i recommend often
people who are vaccine hesitant because
they might have had covet and they think
that they're that their immunity is
being ignored i tell them well elite
it's not being ignored just get one dose
and johnson johnson a single dose
vaccine so you get your vaccine card so
you can be called fully vaccinated and
you get the benefit or the boost that
that one dose of vaccine will give your
pre-existing immunity
do you think that the so most people i
know in canada i'm from canada have
modern or the pfizer vaccine which is
two dose
and there's i guess i don't know uh on
the news you can see that potentially
it's going to require boosters so do you
think this this is going to be something
that's like the flu vaccine that you get
once a year or you get every six months
or something in order to keep covet less
virulent i guess
it really goes back to what we want the
vaccine to do and like i said earlier
what we want to do with this vaccine or
what i want the vaccine to do is prevent
serious disease hospitalization and
death and when you look at people who
got the pfizer and modern vaccines we
haven't really seen erosion against
protection against serious disease
except for in some special groups so
those above the age of 65 those with
high risk conditions so that's where i
think boosters benefit the most are
people who are above 65 people of high
risk conditions for an average healthy
person i don't think boosters with these
vaccines that we have now really do
anything but maybe push off a
breakthrough infection sometime into the
future and i don't think that chasing
mild infections and healthy people with
boosters makes a lot of sense and maybe
in canada you won't need boosters as
much because you separated the dose i
think some of their separation and doses
a little bit longer than in the u.s
where we separated pfizer by three and
modern by four in canada there was a
little bit longer duration i think
because of supply issues but that
actually makes the vaccines work better
so hopefully there's not as much of a
need for boosters
with but but i don't think that uh
i think when we talk about the
trajectory of the pandemic boosting
people to stop mild illness isn't going
to really change the trajectory it's
first and second doses that are the most
important and and i think that the
boosters are a little bit of a
distraction although if you're in a
high-risk group or elderly i do think
you would benefit from a booster
um
one of the arguments i've heard put
forth by anti-vaccine proponents was
that there are more deaths in the last
year uh vaccine-related deaths than
there have been ever before have you
heard anything about this
that idea stems from people
misinterpreting this database called
theirs the vaccine adverse injury
reporting system that the cdc has set up
this is basically a catch-all
reporting system that anybody you me
anybody can just report any any reaction
that they might have had after the
vaccine and that's used basically to
look and see is there a signal there for
anything and people are looking at that
raw data of people who happen to die
after getting the vaccine and saying
there's a lot more of them but the thing
is the cdc is telling people report
everything there because we want
everyone to have transparency that
everybody's looking for safety signals
and when you actually adjudicate the
deaths that are being reported in the
vera system they're not related to the
vaccine uh to a high degree and i think
that this is a misuse of that database
which is meant for researchers to
basically sift through
reams of data
and try and figure out what is a causal
relationship between the vaccine and
some side effect and what is a
correlation remember just because
something happens after you were
vaccinated doesn't mean it was caused by
the vaccine and that's something that is
being lost when people actually report
look at that database without any
training let any understanding of its
context and then just put those numbers
out of out of completely out of context
and then use that against the vaccine
and against vaccine safety when that
whole system is meant to be vaccine safe
vaccine safety system so this is uh one
area that's very frustrating that this
those numbers keep getting quoted out of
context and and cited as if they're
actually
causally linked to the vaccine
okay there's a fair response i think i
have one more major question
this is another argument that's
frequently brought up by the
anti-vaccine community community is that
vaccine companies pharmaceutical
companies don't have a liability
protection
but they have liability protection if
they can mandate vaccines in kids
apparently once a vaccination is
mandated in children and that would be
through the government
they get liability protection
do you know anything about that
so this goes back to a little bit what
we were talking about with the vaccine
court so first of all in the united
states no vaccines are mandated as a
condition of life for children there are
school requirements that are those are
different and then there is a pan there
is the cdc which recommends vaccine so
what happens is when the cdc officially
recommends a vaccine saying this is
something that children should get
that gets
that gives a vaccine a certain status
doesn't mean that it's mandated because
not every child is vaccinated against
measles or influenza for example but
they're also they're all recommended to
be vaccinated that allows
that that vaccine court to think that
vaccine court to be triggered so it's
not as if they have
complete
that there's no recourse if someone gets
a vaccine injury it's just that it moves
to that vaccine court and that's where
that this type of issue is handled
versus in the open court which maybe for
example if you get a vaccine that's not
recommended or not approved or not
doesn't have that same level of evidence
behind it you might go through the
traditional courts maybe it's a travel
vaccine or some or a vaccine or a
vaccine that's not recommended for the
general public
and you get that then you probably have
a different there's a different pathway
but once something
is endorsed by the cdc as a
recommendation is put on the childhood
recommended vaccines which are not the
same as mandates then i think you use
you use that other alternative court
system obviously i'm not a public health
lawyer in in some of these
some of the details i might be a little
bit off on but that's my best
understanding of it i've heard that
there's a link and i don't know if this
is true again between chickenpox and
shingles that you get the chickenpox
vaccine as a kid you have immunity but
it only lasts seven to ten years then
you're not immune anymore and because
you don't have that natural childhood
immunity you can grow up and you can end
up with shingles which is way worse
and apparently they don't vaccinate
against chickenpox in the uk
and that has something to do with the
fact that
people might get shingles when they're
later because they don't have the
initial immunity to chickenpox because
the chickenpox vaccine wears off how do
you feel about that
it's a little bit jumbled up there so
i'm going to try and i'm going to kind
of give you good luck one lesson so
chicken pox and shingles are caused by
the same virus so when you get
chickenpox
you don't if you get chickenpox you get
infected with chickenpox that virus it
never leaves your body it's actually
part of the herpes virus family so
herpes viruses stay with you for life
chickenpox stays with you for life so
you get infected you get the chickenpox
you get the rash people get that as a
child
then
years later decades later as you get
older that virus reawakens it might
reawaken because you're older it might
reawaken because you're on
immunosuppressants or you get ill or you
have trauma or something
and you get shingles that's so that's
the relationship you get chickenpox as a
child it reactivates later in life as
shingles
and what what happened was they
developed a chickenpox vaccine so that
actually aborts the entire process
because you don't get infected with
chickenpox so then therefore you don't
get shingles so it's actually the exact
opposite of the way it was presented to
you so the chickenpox vaccine is
something that would prevent you from
getting shingles because if you don't
get chickenpox you cannot get shingles
and the vaccine seems to be very robust
uh we give it in two doses and there and
for people who like me who got
chickenpox
i got infected with chickenpox when i
was in eighth grade i'm at risk for
shingles when i get to a certain age
there's another vaccine a shingles
vaccine that you can take to prevent
that reactivation or that reawakening
that occurs so it's actually the other
way around and i think that the
chickenpox vaccine is likely to change
the way shingles occurs because it's
going to become less common because it's
not something that's out there anymore
because people aren't getting infected
with chickenpox so
this is a this is puzzling to me that
people have put have used this against
the chickenpox vaccine because it's
actually probably the exact opposite of
the truth
uh is the shingles vaccine just the
chickenpox vaccine is it the same thing
it's very similar to the chickenpox
vaccine but it's a higher dose vaccine
than the chickenpox vaccine
okay
okay
okay
i think those are all the questions i
had do you have anything else you want
to add
just that i think it's it's incredible
how many vaccines that we do have and
how vaccines have really
added decades of life to every person
and prevented hundreds of millions of
deaths i think that their technological
marvels and i think it's to me
mind-boggling to see people turn against
what's one of the you know the pillars
of what's made you know our our
childhoods something that are idyllic
and not
fraught with hearing about our friends
with measles or our friends dying our
friends in hospitals
people in africa line up overnight
just to get access to certain vaccines
that we take for granted like the
measles bumps and rubella vaccine and
and i think it's just uh
to me a very
sad state of affairs when we see people
uh turning away from what i think are
are life enhancing products that that
everyone benefits from
okay where can people find you online or
where should they go if they want to
learn more
the best way to interact with me or to
follow me is on twitter it's amish a a
so a-m-e-s-h-a-a
great thank you very much for coming on
thanks for having me
[Music]
you